yeah hello and welcome to this video
which looks a bit different than usual
because of the webcam
yeah I'm currently in Berlin doing
commentary on the candidates tournament
today is the fourth session that I'm
going to do commentary on was very
enjoyable to be as so close to the the
top players and doing ya live commentary
when you don't really know how it's
going to enter every game it's very very
em thrilling I'm doing this video a to
point out that the introductory offer
for my keep it simple Evo repertoire is
going to end in roughly two days as you
see there's the counter here on the
website one day 22 hours and 18 minutes
left
so that will be the morning hours some
in Europe in two days um
the important thing is that you really
can save a lot of money if you go for
them yeah now introductory price as you
see him the pure book here the move
trainer opening ebook is now on sale for
$14.99 dollars and it will be a $24.99
in yeah in two days when this offer ends
so there's a nice saving of almost fifty
percent if you are going to go for the
introductory price and there's the video
version the video Edition that is
currently priced as a total of $80 or
seventy nine ninety eight yeah so this
is the the e-book plus the video so that
if you just count the video it is sixty
five and this is really a steal at the
current current price for close to 17
hours of video um and this is going to
be 160 after the sale ends so there you
can really save 50% on the price so if
you really am think of getting it and
always wanted to get it but forgot
get forgotten to buy them um yeah go for
it now in the next yeah what is that
forty forty six yeah forty six hours um
also take note if you are unsure about
the whole thing do you really like it is
it for you yeah you have this 30-day
money-back guarantee that you can see
him it's a very simple process and we'll
there will be no problem at all if you
in fact find out that you don't like it
I'm have to say though that the
reception of the whole repertoire was
excellent so far we have four hundred
and fifty buyers already and if I'm not
mistaken we only had one person who
wanted his money back the general
reception is excellent so um if you
wanted to get it anyway make sure to do
it rather soonish because it will save
you a lot of money and we will probably
have a sale again but this is going to
be month until this happens so if you
want to do it now another thing and that
I wanted to point out is how this
learning on chess table works and this
is something that I wanted to show you
real quickly even though my screen real
estate is a little bit a little bit
problematic what is that
okay sign up is wrong I should log in
half of an account so um how does that
learning actually work there is first of
all the learning process where you get
to show when you moves get to show to
you and you get all the texts and
everything but there's also the
reviewing that means the repetition of
the of the lines that make sure that you
actually keep everything in mind and
remember it as you see him I've got all
the other ten chapters mastered already
I've learned it all once you have to
really know my own repertoire
now there's the leader board here where
you can see that I'm actually one of the
most active students of
one record one so I have learned every
single move and repeated it once for me
it's a repetition because I wrote it but
what what do you do at the end well what
do you do have to have learned it all
you can click on review and this is
something that will be extremely useful
the software will ok you should say this
you are playing black why am I playing
black no I'm not playing like so it will
point out positions to you that you have
learned and now you should yeah enter
the correct moves so what should I play
here I mean if you want to find a move
now it's ok you can but it's better if
you know that ninety six is strong and
they're just going to ask you positions
that you have seen before Queen h5 is
right yeah you take on h6
you take with the Queen and so on if you
know those things they can enter this
real quickly note that there are
different there are various settings
that you can use you can use it with
them with the timer I now set it without
a time of it this is something that is
up to you your queen h5 is right auntie
I should definitely recapture the Queen
yeah oh yeah that's also not so bad I
take only six threatening made on f7
until you go back you have to cover C
form so it asks you those questions what
are you going to do now ya think f4 is
correct yeah if I remember correctly
it's f4 is correct and now you gain a
couple of experience points and then you
click next lesson and you get the next
position and okay here D takes e5 is
right note that you don't get the text
the the texts that are attached to the
most because that is part of the initial
learning process if you however do
something wrong then you get the texts
again so like here I know that Queen d5
is right and I can put that on the board
and the OB ship g5 is right
and now what am I doing here I think I'm
taking at the knight c3 yeah that's it
through first is probably also not
terrible but until you take and so on
and I know the most um but what happens
if you enter something wrong I can do
that let's let's play Knight bTW -
probably not a completely terrible move
but not to move that the software wants
you to play because 9c3 is certainly
correct but let's do it
it says incorrect move 93 and it shows
you all 93 is right okay
so you are again here and 93 and so on
it shows you what you made wrong and
shows you the writing when it will
repeat that position at a certain time
and then you hopefully get it in
correctly you get the the right move
entered so this is the repetition mode
that the revenue mode that shows you all
the positions again - just make sure
that you let you remember it and this is
something that that is really am quickly
done yeah like you just enter enter the
moves real quickly it take and here
probably have three is right yeah prize
yeah yeah yeah and now it asks you again
and I midnight BD - last time and now
hopefully I know that nice is free is
right here so let's do it and again
lights is reality it repeats that
because you made this wrong you made a
mistake there and that make sure that
you get the positions on the board that
you actually have trouble to remember
against f5 this Bishop c4 I think you
get the idea if I'm now doing something
wrong like Eli takes e5 is correct yeah
and black gets blown off the board and
I'm going to play a stupid book
I just incorrectly I'm not xe5 okay and
it will repeat that is really really
nice a little bit later I get this again
and then hopefully I remember that night
65 is the right decision so um I think
it's an excellent tool I have used it a
lot
self as you can see from the from the
leaderboard score I've one of them one
of the yeah most active students of my
own repertoire and this way I'm making
sure that I really remember what what I
have written
and then this initial stage okay hope
you enjoy to this video I look into this
repertoire again and yeah make sure to
make use the make use of the
introductory offer because it's a really
great amount of money that you can save
if you intend to get it it would be a
bit of a shame if you always wanted to
buy it and then you take three days and
see oh now I have to pay double the
money thanks for watching bye bye